What have you become
I am what you made me
Welcome back everyone this
will be my full star wars obi-wan kenobi episode
3 video we finally got a whole bunch of hayden
christensen darth vader and anakin skywalker
surprisingly with james earl jones coming back to
do the voice one of our first rematches between
them of the series there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs to break down so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what your favorite part of
their rematch was during the episode careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet but
we could talk about darth vader and obi-wan
kenobi rematch all day long there's so much
to unpack from their reunion during the episode
this is their first actual reunion and the first
time the obi-wan kenobi has ever seen anakin
skywalker wearing the darth vader sith armor
and that's only the half of it like apparently
obi-wan kenobi has a brother in a family out there
somewhere so there are potentially other young
force-sensitive kenobis that can show up in other
star wars live-action projects but i'll start at
the beginning of the episode and we'll just work
our way through shot by shot talking about easter
eggs wtf moments as we go along one of the weird
things about the series is they're not calling the
episodes by different special titles they're just
calling this part one part two part three part
four all the way up to part six because it's a
six episode series it's meant to be more like a
movie that they chopped into six different parts
but they started the episode with that brand
new john williams obi-wan kenobi theme music
for the episode and throughout the episode you
probably picked up a lot of familiar themes
from the original trilogy there's a lot of john
williams baked into the new music for the series
especially when they have a lot of anakin
skywalker darth vader and obi-wan kenobi moments
but as predicted he begins this episode again
also calling for qui-gon jinn's help just further
setting up a big cameo scene for him later in the
series i literally just posted a video all about
qui-gon jinn showing up on the series so i'll
post a link for that down in the description below
there's been several easter eggs already for him
actually showing up and teaching obi-wan kenobi
to become a force ghost and he just keeps calling
for him so i think eventually we're going to hear
him speaking to him in new dialogue the actual
opening scene is him just processing everything
realizing that anakin skywalker are still alive
darth vader is out there and they have this big
montage of darth vader suiting up after he comes
out of his back the tank in his castle on mustafar
while that's going on he's busy having this ptsd
flashback to all the different prequel movies in
specific moments like moments from revenge of the
sith moments of anakin skywalker dialogue qui-gon
jinn's voice-over dialogue yoda's voice-over
dialogue just talking about pain also anakin
blaming the jedi and obi-wan for everything bad
that had happened to him which he does again later
in the episode when he's in full darth vader sith
armor but obviously because qui-gon jinn hasn't
come back as a force spirit to speak to him yet
all the qui-gon jinn voice voice-over dollop is
from phantom menace before he wound up dying love
the way they end that montage too with you hearing
darth vader's heavy breathing sound as the rest
of the armor gets put on him and it is meant to be
hayden christensen actually underneath the armor
unless they have him do some crazy action scenes
in later episodes then they would have a stunt
double do that stuff but mostly it's supposed to
be hayden christensen and just like the classic
trilogy it is james earl jones doing his voice
when he has the armor on where is he everything
with him just laying into the inquisitors not
caring about them is right out of the cannon darth
vader really did not care about what happened to
anybody within the empire now like he doesn't
care about the inquisitors during this like oh
he's dead grand inquisitor who cares about him i
only care about you finding obi-wan kenobi don't
fail me or i'll probably kill you too what's going
on inside his head right now is that the last 10
years yes he's been hunting down the various force
sensitives the other jedi trying to turn them
and killing the ones that would not turn to the
dark side that's all about reva's arc i'll talk
about that in a second too because there are a
couple moments later in the episode where they
reference that we don't know what happens
to the young leaves we never see them again
that's because they either get turned to the
dark side and become inquisitors like reva
or they just wind up killing them but one of
the funnier things about darth vader this is
kind of an in-joke with the fandom is that
he will kill anybody empire or rebellion
doesn't matter anyone who displeases him they
said at this whole running plot line with reva
being super ambitious and kind of explaining that
she wants the new position of grand inquisitor but
like we talked about during my episode two video
i do not think that he's totally dead like unless
they completely break canada which i guess
is possible but i'm not expecting it they're
sort of setting her up to get her own comeuppance
like your ambition will be your own downfall when
he tells krennic not to choke quote unquote on
his ambition as he's literally force choking him
they also said of all this infighting within the
inquisitors too this big rivalry between all of
them so as much as they all want to find obi-wan
kenobi and either kill him or torture him for a
long long time it sounds like everybody within the
inquisitor's ranks also want to do that to reva
as well as each other as well one of the other
cool things you probably detected under this is
they have some new darth vader music that they're
playing under this it's obviously echoes of the
original trilogy theme music like every time you
see darth vader on screen there's echoes of that
classic john williams theme music but a lot of
this is brand new music for these characters
and even the obi-wan kenobi's having this big ptsd
flashback he does wind up helping fix leia's droid
lola which i think will probably wind up helping
them later in the timeline i think that's why they
tried to show you that lola was pretty useful
in the first episode when they introduced her
character and yes it does look kind of like the
robots from batteries not included and they are as
predicted selling it as a toy in real life right
now they arrive at mapuzo which is meant to be
another backwater mining planet in the mid rim
remember a lot of the series is taking place in
and around the mid rim which is where alderaan is
located is closer to the emperor's locus of power
the further out you go in the galaxy like once
you get to the outer rim the empire is still a
big presence but they have way less forces that
far out that's why they keep saying that a lot of
the jedi who are hiding out the people that make
it through the underground railroad that they have
go to the outer rim and take up new identities
for example right now ahsoka tano is in hiding
in another outer rim planet grogu is also
currently hiding out in some other outer
rim planet that we don't know about when they
arrive at the port there's an r5 droid there's
actually a bunch of r5 droids throughout the
episode they introduce this new type of ned b
droid that's working in a bunch of different
capacities while they're mining the planet
there's this whole subplot with it not being able
to speak like the droids can't speak but they do
seem like they want to help them i think they'll
end up paying that off in next week's episode
the droids will somehow try to help them fight
the empire the real big wtf moment here though
is obi-wan kenobi legit having a hallucination
of anakin skywalker just further foreshadowing
their first reunion later in the episode it's not
meant to be a force ghost anakin or a trick of the
force or anything or like a force vision it's just
like a legit mental ptsd hallucination he's still
in that headspace where he's thinking about the
reveal that anakin is still alive so he's just
thinking about anakin skywalker in general then
when they jump back to the inquisitor storyline we
see the fortress inquisitorius for the first time
and i believe they're calling their ship here the
scythe the fortress is located on one of the other
moons of mustafar in the mustafar system so it's
pretty close to darth vader's castle but it's not
on the same planet it looks pretty close to what
it looks like during star wars rebels during
jedi fallen order it's featured during a lot
of different things so a lot of you probably seen
versions of this in different aspects before they
do a bunch of stuff here it's basically a facility
for keeping the inquisitor's military forces like
there are a bunch of other random stormtroopers
running around they use it for torturing jedi or
force sensitives who won't turn to the dark side
and become inquisitors in their quest to find more
who survived order 66 they also use it for basic
training for the people who do wind up turning to
the dark side this is this whole running storyline
with younglings that have been captured too so
there might be other younglings somewhere inside
this fortress that obi-wan winds up helping rescue
but i think the whole thing with younglings
is more of a reference to reva's storyline
in talking about what happened to her like what is
her actual story why did she turn to the dark side
they give you a little bit of a tour of it
we'll probably see more of it in later episodes
too when she walks through the hangar bay into the
meeting room they play a version of the imperial
march just like a slightly different version
that they can post for this episode i believe
in the background here too they have a bunch
of lightsabers on display from jedi who they've
either killed or they turn to the dark side they
continue to set this big rivalry that she has with
the fifth brother the other inquisitors this other
female inquisitor is the fourth sister she's the
third sister this whole scene where they send
out the probe droids to is meant to have a lot
of vibes for empire strikes back when darth vader
and the imperial send out the pro droids to hoth
except because special effects have gotten so much
better in present day they have a little bit more
fun with it so they actually show you the line
of all the probe droids getting ready to launch
when obi-wan mentions their fake backstory on
tall that planet hasn't appeared in the canon
before so it's brand new to the series there are
a couple of people and a couple things that are
brand new to the episode but usually you will
see them work in deep cuts for a lot of things
the joke about obi-wan's daughter you could take
as a wink in his almost relationship with duchess
satine of the mandalorians but canonically he's
not supposed to have any biological children
there's just lots of fan theories out there
that he might have had a child at some point
the names that leia uses luma actually did show up
inside the black spire outpost recently that's the
live-action star wars attraction at disneyland in
disney world the name ordon that obi-wan is using
though is brand new to star wars the mole creature
freck might actually be a deep cut easter egg for
that 1986 droids animated series the old school
one during that there were a sentient mole race on
tatooine that looked kind of similar to the one
on the tv show and i believe this is our first
celebrity cameo too i think this is meant to be
zach braff doing a special voice as the mole man
here so he's unrecognizable but it is supposed to
be zach braff the whole thing with his character
is that he's not meant to be shady or anything
like that despite the fact that he's working
within the empire they're just trying to show you
what life is like underneath imperial rule now
and remember this is in the mid rim so the forces
of the empire way stronger here way more present
the whole idea that the empire was able to
continue this way because billions and billions of
people supported their rule like he says oh isn't
it great to have order now don't we love it now
and he's not meant to be evil or anything
like that he's just like this common worker
just oblivious to like the really crazy stuff
that the empire is doing then they have this
big funny scene with the stormtroopers who are
completely oblivious to who obi-wan kenobi and
leia really are even though he completely
gives away their identity during their talk
when he says stormtroopers are very good at
their job it's just a joke about how incompetent
stormtroopers have been in the history of
star wars they did the same thing during
the mandalorian season one with the scout troopers
who were just completely incompetent when they're
leaving though one of the stormtroopers mentions
a t16 which is another callback to luke's t-16
bullseye womp rats and baker's canyon in the model
t-16 that obi-wan tried to give him early in the
episodes or will eventually successfully give him
in the future that we later see him playing with
during a new hope obi-wan talks to her about padme
and anakin skywalker he references his own parents
and his brother apparently which is actually
a brand new thing i don't think they've ever
referenced obi-wan having a brother previously
in the canon mother's shawl father's hands i
remember a baby a baby yes i think i had a brother
obi-wan having a brother who is potentially still
alive out there in the galaxy is our best hope at
having more kenobis in the future of star wars if
he himself didn't have biological children he
along with normal jedi candidates padawans were
taken when they're about four years old so that
they don't develop attachments to their families
which became a big problem obviously for anakin
skywalker that's why later when luke skywalker
goes to yoda to be trained in empire strikes back
he grumbles about him being too old nope too old
to begin the training just like his father obi-wan
was born on the stew-john system they referenced
that in his original family a little during the
novelization for phantom menace george lucas is
actually the person who came up with the name of
obi-wan's planet stu john it's a play on the name
jon stewart the actual tv host because at this
convention he asked george lucas where did obi-wan
come from originally in on the spot george lucas
just said oh he came from stu john he just made
it up literally on stage and thus it became star
wars canon and his mother and father have never
shown up in the animation or live action series
before maybe at some point they'll do some more
backstory for him in the animated episodes they
hit the next checkpoint in a probe droid winds
up identifying him queuing up darth vader and
the inquisitors learning about their presence
i believe this is also our first wilhelm
scream that we get during the series 2. it
wouldn't be star wars if you didn't hear at
least one wilhelm scream during the series
then they introduced indira varma's imperial
captain character and she winds up being their
contact her name is tala she's brand new to the
star wars canon she's never appeared before she's
just someone who's sympathetic to the jedi's
plight it also sounds like the underground
railroad that she operates here with quinlan vos
of all people another jedi that winds up showing
up from the cannon wind up helping smuggle just
pretty much anybody who's running from the empire
but they specifically reference jedi and force
sensitives she's supposed to be the person who
haja had sent them to visit and it's all meant
to be the storyline about obi-wan kenobi finding
hope because earlier they had this whole thing
with obi-wan thinking that hajah did them dirty
everybody's terrible why should we have any kind
of hope cut to later in the episode where he does
see a lot of cases of normal people helping him
and doing good things so by the end of the series
he will recognize oh there are good people out
there it is possible for good things to happen
again but the way that tala talks about it she
said that she and quinlan vos have been helping
many jedi and force sensitives before him but
like i said they kind of set this whole running
story line meant to dovetail with reva's plot in
what winds up happening to the jedi younglings and
the other four sensitives that the inquisitors are
able to capture if you've played jedi fallen order
it's right out of that storyline and big easter
egg a lot of that is taking place around the same
time that this is taking place one of the other
points of interest here too is that when that
second group of stormtroopers that indira varma's
tala character winds up taking out shows up to
take obi-wan kenobi you actually hear a female
stormtrooper's voice which is actually pretty rare
in the star wars canon now normally the empire
recruits equal opportunities so there are just as
many women stormtroopers as there are male storm
troopers it's just that in the live-action star
wars movies the series before you don't see a ton
of female stormtroopers so that's what makes this
scene kind of rare when they make it back to town
and leia apologizes to him for running away she's
actually talking about running away the first
time back on alderaan when she was captured in
the first place they introduced the ned b droid
while she's talking about lola just to set up i
think the droids wind up helping them in the next
episode escape then when she starts talking about
quinlan voss the other jedi who survive order 66
helping her out with this underground railroad
helping other force sensitives out i think it
is possible that we could see a big cameo scene
with him either in later episodes or in a future
series like they wouldn't go through the trouble
of actually mentioning him by name if they weren't
actually going to use him as a character everybody
just waiting for them to name drop mace windu at
some point the way she explains it is what they
do is they'll smuggle them to the outer rim or
they'll give them new identities and they'll just
hide out kind of like what's happening with ahsoka
tana right now like she's going by an assumed name
not using her jedi abilities quite as much the
same way that grogu is just trying to go to ground
it was also what haja was trying to help that
other kid and his mother do in episode two he
was force sensitive and they were trying to
escape the empire there are a bunch of jedi
scrawlings all over the walls of all the force
sensitives and the other jedi who have passed
through there this is the symbol of the jedi
order the message that quinlan vos left and
they read specifically said only when the eyes are
closed can you truly see the way this meant to be
an easter egg for a couple different things it's
meant to be a reference for the original trilogy
where you saw obi-wan kenobi closing his eyes
as darth vader was getting ready to kill him
because it was him seeing the way to eternal life
but i think it's also meant to be a metaphor for
this series for the jedi force vision power
like foresight closing his eyes when he's
facing vader so that his other senses in the force
become more powerful making him a better fighter
despite the fact that a lot of his abilities have
waned in the last 10 years of him not using them
so i think he'll wind up using this technique
during one of his rematch fights with darth vader
they make another reference to leia being a good
fighter when she's older just another reference
to the events of the original trilogy then the
reason obi-wan kenobi has this panic attack as
they get ready to escape is because he's sensing
darth vader's presence in the force it's like this
miasma of dark side energy that enters this arena
here then i love the way they do this big darth
vader reveal they start with this heavy breathing
first like you hear the breath then they do a
slow reveal starting with his boots working up the
sith armor and remember this is the first time the
obi-wan kenobi has seen anakin skywalker wearing
the sith armor so even though he doesn't actually
know that it's him he can sense him through the
force so he knows that it is anakin like oh my
god it's him and you do also see that darth vader
is able to sense obi-wan kenobi's presence through
the force that's why he keeps looking around all
over the place as he darts around also r.i.p to
all those common towns people that darth vader
took out with the force as he was walking up
trying to find obi-wan kenobi he just seems
like he's really worked up just really really
pissed off ready for that fight big thing though
remember he doesn't know anything about leia so
if he's sensing someone in the force he thinks
that it's obi-wan kenobi but he might actually
be sensing leia through the force and just not
realizing that it's her also that he's sensing
then we get our first legit obi-wan kenobi versus
darth vader rematch scene it is brief this first
time even though they kind of drag it a little bit
he's mostly just trying to lead darth vader away
from leia so that she can escape when he speaks
to him for the first time he mostly taunts him
and references the events of revenge of the sith
about how he still blames obi-wan kenobi for
everything bad that has happened to him i am what
you made me remember it's only been 10 years since
that happened and even though it seems like it's
been a long time darth vader is still super pissed
off about the way things went down and he's been
obsessed with obi-wan kenobi for the last 10 years
so this whole scene of their rematch here is like
him trying to enjoy the moment just dragging him
along having fun with his dinner so to speak
taunting obi-wan kenobi trying to make him feel
all the same pain that he felt during revenge of
the sith love the opening shot of him igniting the
red lightsaber too just to show you how much he's
changed the last 10 years he's also been trying to
snuff out everything that has remained of anakin
skywalker within him too obviously that winds up
being unsuccessful because ultimately by return of
the jedi luke skywalker's able to help him redeem
himself but at this point the pain is all still
fresh in his mind this is also the first time
that we've seen obi-wan kenobi use his lightsaber
since revenge of the sith that we know of i mean
he may have used it briefly when he first came
to tatooine but it sounds like he hasn't used
it in about 10 years the other funny thing
you may have recognized during this is that
you hear a lot of darth vader's emotes a lot of
his grunting sounds that's all right out of the
classic original trilogy you hear a lot of these
classic darth vader sound effects if you play a
lot of the video games too when he's taunting
obi-wan kenobi about growing weak in the last
10 years it's mostly because obi-wan stopped
using his abilities the same thing happened
to grogu like he had to start remembering his
training with luke skywalker's help but it's also
meant to be a clever easter egg for the original
trilogy in a new hope with their lightsaber fight
because that fight was way simpler than the last
fight you saw them have during revenge of the sith
so they kind of want to explain canonically why
their lightsaber technique changes so much and
becomes so much simpler in that time gap between
those movies the reason why it seems like darth
vader has grown way less nimble even though he's
grown more powerful in the dark side of the force
even during rogue one it seems like his technique
has slowed down just a little bit like he's not
quite as nimble it's because he's had to adapt
his fighting technique to that really heavy sith
armor that he's wearing so literally he's just not
quite as quick as he used to be even though he is
still very powerful all the music during their
fight scene here has echoes of the classic john
williams darth vader theme music but most of it is
meant to be brand new music for the episode their
fight scene is actually very reminiscent of darth
vader's first fight scene with luke skywalker in
empire strikes back when he was mostly stalking
him trying to capture him and turn him to the dark
side except the difference here is that he's not
trying to capture obi-wan kenobi to turn him he
just wants to torture him for a long long time
one of my favorite wtf moments too is when he
literally tries to recreate the torture scene from
revenge of the sith where he wants to burn obi-wan
kenobi the same way that he burned on mustafar
that is hardcore but remember he's been obsessed
about this for the last 10 years so that's why he
seems like he's enjoying this so much tala is able
to rescue him from the stormtroopers briefly so
they'll have to deal with that and try to escape
and save leia during episode 4 next week and while
he was trying to lead darth vader away they did
have that whole subplot with reva finding and
capturing leia so r.i.p to that transport pilot
that she took out like i said though next week's
episode will mostly be about them escaping and
they try to set the whole thing with the ned b
droids rising up and trying to help them so i
think that will be the key to them actually making
it off planet but as part of the reva storyline
and learning about what happens to the young
links and the way that they twist them to the
dark side and try to make them into inquisitors i
think eventually we'll see obi-wan kenobi back at
the fortress inquisitorius because there is a big
fight scene in the trailers inside that hangar bay
this seems like they are trying to fight obi-wan
kenobi but it was a great episode loved all the
darth vader scenes just loved the slow reveal and
then just hearing him again for the first time and
seeing hayden christensen as anakin skywalker even
though it was a hallucination i'm really hoping we
see some of that during the ahsoka series as well
if you spotted any big easter eggs in the episode
that i didn't talk about in the video just write
down below in the comments i will do a bunch of
darth vader bonus videos this week too there's so
much to talk about my full obi-wan kenobi episode
4 video will post next week after they release
it and i'll name a giveaway winner in my next big
star wars video everyone click here for that brand
new obi-wan kenobi qui-gon jinn video to learn
what's going on with him and click here for my
full mandalorian season 3 trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!